alerte générale les Français ne font
plus de bébé ça se confirme alors ils en
font encore un petit peu mais de moins
en moins l'INSEE vient de publier son
bilan de naissance sur la première
partie de l'année 2023 en juillet il y a
eu en moyenne 1907 naissances par jour
c'est-à-dire quasiment 9 % de moins que
l'an dernier à la même période c'est le
13e mois consécutif de baisse de 30 ans
que je n'avais pas été aussi bas il a
l'air d'un petit ange mais cette
commande de jouer à 900 euros peut vous
en faire douter impaire à surpris son
fils de 5 ans en train de discuter avec
Alexa l'assistant vocal d'Amazon
deux heures de conversation plus tard
112 toboggans un jacuzzi 45
talkie-walkie et une fusée avait été
ajoutée au panier heureusement pour les
parents les achats ont tous pu être
annulés les raisons inventées il y en a
plein qui sont nombreuses difficultés
économiques actualités anxiogène
précarité évidemment question écologique
aussi vous le
disiez si la baisse de la fertilité
qu'on a plus tard et donc moins en
invertivité le taux de fécondité est
aujourd'hui de 1,84 enfants par femme ce
qui est peu mais élevé si on ne peut pas
[Musique]